is your girlfriend literally about to go
into labor any minute she's crowning
right now actually I actually have this
star wars-themed on my phone so when she
goes into labor it's like it's like yeah
any day now any second day I wish I had
days I got second tonight it could be
the night right she's crowning right now
I'm she's right now why are you here
I had a work I gotta do in every with
you everything's ready to go I have such
a support like a huge support system
from all of my crazy maniac friends that
they've bought her everything that she
needs part of fatherhood are you most
looking forward to you know I've watched
Nicole and Jenny have kids and only have
kids and like their success in all of
our success and it's like to finally
have someone to like look up to me and
show me that unconditional love and
everything I do is gonna make them proud
and like they're gonna be proud of me
that that's like a great feeling to have
deep down inside it's a little girl so
are you gonna be so insanely protective
she's gonna be homeschooled till she's
35
you're home cool to 35 you want a
boyfriend you gotta move out of course
Sammy is not coming back this season are
you guys at least still on friendly
terms
me and Sam we've been done for about
three years we ended on a term that it
is what it is and she chose to move on
their chapter in her life where it did
not choose Jersey Shore and I chose
yours Essure and we all support her as a
group and whatever makes her happy he
makes her happy you know I can't judge
her for it yeah so no bad blood though
no no bad luck no we support everything
she does I gotta ask you about this
trailer that came out today it looks
like maybe you had a little bit too much
fun in Miami I got a pregnant girlfriend
if Ronnie gets any closer to this girl
he's about to have a second baby mama
you'll see how it plays out throughout
the season I put myself in certain
situations no pun intended but it's how
you come out of the situation that's
what you do at the end and it's like do
certain things that you know we're gonna
get ratings you know a lot of people are
gonna watch you know that people are
gonna be interested in like that's what
I had to do Jen gonna feel watching I'm
told her everything that has happened
you know there's nothing that has
happened that I'm regrettable about you
know happen
but at the end you know what's up and
you know what's really important
engagement is that happening you know I
take one base one step at a time and the
next ring I'm gonna buy is a teething
ring so you know I feel like marriage is
a big pressure on something like people
you know like you put that word in
marriage on a relationship and it makes
everything so much more tense and so
much more like you know and but it's
like if I love you you love me let's
enjoy our lives we had a good time
before let's have a good time after we
don't need that if you need a title to
represent your relationship then you
shouldn't be together
season two will you be back I will be
back and I'll be back with the vengeance
[Music]